SO WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE IN THE SWING SPACE. I
WOULD ASK THAT MEMBERS, WHEN
AVAILABLE, WILL COME DOWN. WE DO
HAVE MULTIPLE COMPETING HEARINGS,
SO WE'LL ESTABLISH QUORUM THE
MOMENT WE HAVE TEN PRESENT.
WE'LL HEAR PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER
THE SINGLE OR THE TWO ITEMS ON
THE AGENDA ARE PRESENTED. AND
AGAIN, WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM
YET. SO WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. WE'RE HEARING TWO
BILLS TODAY, AB 180, WHICH IS A
BUDGET BILL, JUNIOR FOR THE 2024
BUDGET ACT, AB 218. A BUDGET
TRAILER BILL TOGETHER, THESE
BILLS INCLUDE AMENDMENTS AND
RESOURCES NECESSARY FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF A 2022 LAW
THAT WE PASSED SENATE BILL 1135
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ RELATED TO
HEALTH PROTECTION ZONES AND
ADDITIONAL MONITORING AND LEAK
DETECTION PLANS FOR OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS. WE HEARD SIGNIFICANT
PUBLIC COMMENT AND DISCUSSION ON
THIS TOPIC IN OUR MONDAY HEARING
ON THE BUDGET PACKAGE. I'M
PLEASED THAT THE MEASURES BEFORE
US TODAY REFLECT AN AGREEMENT
AMONG THE ADMINISTRATION, SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY, SO WE WILL HEAR
HAVE PRESENTATION ON THESE TWO
BILLS, HEAR PUBLIC COMMENT, AND
THEN AS SOON AS WE CAN ESTABLISH
A QUORUM, WE WILL VOTE. THE VICE
CHAIR IS NOT HERE. SO I WOULD
OTHERWISE OFFER HIM AN
OPPORTUNITY. HERE HE IS. MR.
VICE CHAIR, IF YOU'D LIKE TO
MAKE A FEW COMMENTS. SORRY TO
PUT YOU ON THE SPOT. I COULD BE
REDUNDANTLY REDUNDANT AGAIN, BUT
I WILL JUST LET MY WORDS FROM
OUR LAST COMMITTEE MEETING AND
ON THE FLOOR YESTERDAY, OR
WHENEVER THAT WAS, STAND ON
THEIR OWN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GREAT. THANK YOU, MR. VICE
CHAIR. YOU HAVE IMPECCABLE
TIMING, BY THE WAY. YEAH OKAY.
SO THE WE'LL NOW TURN IT OVER TO
ERICA LEE. CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FOR AN OVERVIEW OF THE BILLS
TODAY. AND THE LÀ IS HERE. IF
ANY QUESTIONS COME UP. GOOD
MORNING, I FEEL LIKE WE'VE JUST
BEEN HERE. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
WIENER VICE CHAIR. AND MEMBERS
OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE. ERICA
LEE, WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, AND AS STATED, I WILL
BE PRESENTING ON TWO BILLS,
RELATED TO IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
1137. I WILL GET RIGHT BACK TO
THAT'S NINE. WE HAVE ONE MORE TO
GO. NO ONE LEAVE, PLEASE. OKAY,
THE FIRST BILL, AB 180, IS A
BUDGET BILL THAT AMENDS THE 2024
BUDGET. AND THIS BILL
APPROPRIATES A TOTAL OF 12.2
MILLION OIL, GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FUND, OR OGA, AND
AUTHORIZES 46 POSITIONS IN THE
2425 FISCAL YEAR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION AND
THE STATE AIR RESOURCES BOARD TO
SUPPORT IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
1137, WHICH ESTABLISHES HEALTH
PROTECTION ZONES IN PROXIMITY TO
OIL AND GAS OPERATIONS, MOVING
ON TO THE SECOND BILL, AB 218 IS
A RESOURCES TRAILER BILL, AND
THIS BILL ALLOCATES 2.6 MILLION
OIL, GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FUND AND 13
POSITIONS TO THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. THE
BILL ALSO EXTENDS THE DATES OF
VARIOUS IMPLEMENTATION DEADLINES
TO REFLECT THE REFERENDUM
RELATED DELAYS TO
IMPLEMENTATION, AS WELL AS A
MORE REFINED TIMELINE NECESSARY
TO ACCOMPLISH SOME REQUIRED
ACTIONS. AND WITH THAT, I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS. GREAT.
THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES, ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE? YES, SENATOR NHIÀU.
DID WE KNOW ABOUT THIS EARLIER
IN THE YEAR? THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE BILL WAS PUT ON HOLD DUE
TO LITIGATION, AND WE DID NOT
KNOW UNTIL THE MIDDLE OF SUMMER
THAT THE PROPONENTS WOULD DROP
THEIR PROPOSITION. OKAY. IF I
MAY HIT THE PAUSE BUTTON FOR A
MOMENT. SORRY TO BE RUDE,
LIGHTNING HAS STRUCK, AND WE
HAVE A QUORUM. SO LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. GRAB IT
WHILE YOU CAN. SENATORS WIENER
PRESENT HERE. BECKER HERE. LIKE
SPEAR. CORTEZ HERE. DOLLY ALSO,
EGGMAN GROVE. LAIRD HERE.
MENGIBAR. NEWMAN. PADILLA
PRESENT. ROTH. CIERTO SKINNER.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WAHAB. WILK.
PRESENT WE HAVE A QUORUM. PLEASE
PROCEED. AND SENATOR NEILL, IN
REGARDS TO DATES, I WILL TURN TO
MY COLLEAGUE WHO CAN LET YOU
KNOW WHEN SOME OF THESE THINGS
HAPPENED. BUT GENERALLY
SPEAKING, WE DID NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THESE RESOURCES. BACK IN JUNE,
WE DIDN'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
THERE WAS A THERE WAS A
REFERENDUM. THERE WAS A THERE
WAS EVERYTHING WAS FROZEN. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THAT WAS,
IT WAS IN JUNE THAT THE
REFERENDUM WAS DROPPED. THAT'S
WHEN WE PASSED THE BUDGET ON
JUNE, 30 15TH. BUT THAT'S WHY
THE DATE. CAN I JUST JUMP IN, SO
IT WAS IT WAS DROPPED AROUND THE
TIME THAT WE WERE PASSING OUR
BUDGET, AND AT THAT POINT IN
TIME, IT BECAME APPARENT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION EXPRESSED THAT
THERE WAS A NEED TO HAVE SOME
SORT OF DELAY DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION DUE TO THE TIME
DELAY THAT THE, THAT THE, OIL
INDUSTRY SPONSORED REFERENDUM
HAD CAUSED. AND SO IT TOOK SOME
TIME TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT
EXACT DELAY WAS. THERE WAS A
DISAGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE, AND THAT'S NOW BEEN
WORKED OUT. SO AND IT CAUSED A
60 DAY, 75 DAY DELAY, WHICH I
THINK IS PRETTY REASONABLE. I'M
SORRY, DID YOU WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING, NO. ZACH, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, I'M HAPPY
TO PROVIDE MORE DETAILS AS WELL
AS THE DATES, BUT, YOU GOT IT.
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION.
COLLEAGUES, ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS? OKAY. SEEING NONE,
WE WILL NOW HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE LÀ YOU'RE HERE FOR
QUESTIONS? ANYTHING TO ADD?
NOPE. GREAT. THANK YOU. WE'LL
NOW OPEN UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
EITHER OF THESE TWO ITEMS? ITEM
ONE OR ITEM TWO? THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. RICK MELMASON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE.
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
REINSTATEMENT OF FUNDING FOR SB
1137 IMPLEMENTATION. I WANT TO
SHARE OUR STRONG AND IMMENSE
THANKS TO THE CHAIR, SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY LEADERSHIP AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR LISTENING TO
ALL THE COMMUNITY VOICES THAT
WERE HERE EARLIER THIS WEEK AND
REINSTATING THIS FUNDING. ALSO
REGISTERING SUPPORT FOR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND,
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR, SAN
FRANCISCO, BAYKEEPER
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE CENTER,
THE CENTER OF THE CLIMATE
CENTER, 350 BAY AREA ACTION
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY,
NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA, AND VOICES
FOR PROGRESS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT ON
EITHER OF THE TWO ITEMS BEFORE
US TODAY? SEEING NONE, WE'LL
CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT AND BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEES.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
DO I HAVE A MOTION ON ITEM
NUMBER ONE? AB 180? SO MOVED BY
SENATOR LAIRD AND WE WILL CALL
THE ROLL. AB 180. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS. SENATOR WIENER AYE.
WIENER. AYE. NIELSEN. NÓ.
NIELSEN. NÓ. BECKER AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR. CORTEZ
CORTESE. AYE. DOLLY. DOLLY. NO
DURAZO. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE.
GROVE. LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE.
MENGIBAR. NEWMAN. PADILLA AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. ROTH. ROTH. AYE.
SEYARTO. SKINNER. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. WAHAB. WILK. NÓ WILK.
NO. OKAY. WE WILL PUT THAT ON
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. WE'LL
NOW GO TO ITEM NUMBER TWO. AB
218. DO I HAVE A MOTION? MOVE,
MOVE. MOVED BY SENATOR CORTEZ,
AND WE'LL CALL THE ROLL. AB 218.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, SENATOR
WIENER. AYE. WIENER. AYE. NHIÀU
NØ NIELSEN. NO. BECKER. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE SPEAR. CORTEZ.
COURTESY. AYE DOLLY. DURAZO
EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE. GROVE
LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE. MENGIBAR
NEUMANN. PADILLA. Ã. PADILLA
AYE. ROTH. ROTH. AYE. SEYARTO
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
WAHAB. WILK. NÓ. WILK NO. OKAY.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL AS WELL.
GOOD JOB. EVERYONE IS NOW
WELCOME TO VACATE AND, SO AT
THIS POINT, WE ARE JUST WAITING
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. AND SO I
THINK WE'LL GO. SHOULD WE? OKAY.
WE'LL TAKE A VERY BRIEF RECESS
UNTIL SOME MORE MEMBERS SHOW UP.
GO BACK AND OUT OF OUR RECESS
AND WE WILL, OPEN THE ROLLS. SO
PLEASE, CALL ABSENT MEMBERS FOR
ITEM ONE, AB 180. AB 180. BLAKE
SPEER, DURAZO GROVE MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR I NEUMANN. CIERTO.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
WAHAB. C . PUT IT BACK ON. CALL
ITEM TWO AB 218. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BLAKE SPEARS,
DAWLEY, DUROSEAU GROVE, MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR I NEWMAN. SEYARTO.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WAHAB PUT THAT BACK ON CALL.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. HOUSING
COMMITTEE. THEY'RE ON. YEAH.
OKAY. YEAH, WE'RE WE'RE HITTING
THE JACKPOT HERE, OKAY. ITEM
NUMBER ONE, AB 180, PLEASE CALL
THE OPPOSITE MEMBERS. BLAKE
SPEER HERE. BLAKE SPEER I ALSO
Ã GROVE NEWMAN. CIERTO.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
WAHAB. WAHHAB. I PUT THAT BACK
ON CALL ITEM TWO AB 218. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SHAKESPEARE. SHAKESPEARE. I
DUROSEAU GROVE. NEWMAN SEYARTO
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WAHAB WAHAB. I WILL PUT IT BACK
ON. CALL. WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK
INTO RECESS.
THUS, AND WE'LL OPEN THE ROLLS.
SO ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB 180.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
DUROSEAU GROVE, NEWMAN, NEWMAN I
SEYARTO SKINNER. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. I WE
WILL PUT IT BACK ON CALL ITEM
TWO AB 218. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DAWLEY DUROSEAU
GROVE. NEWMAN. NEWMAN I SEYARTO.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. I WILL PUT IT
BACK ON CALL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OKAY. AND WE'LL GO BACK IN
THE RECESS.
OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK
FROM RECESS. I DON'T HAVE ANY.
BE LIKE EGGMAN, DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT. OKAY, SO WE WILL NOW
OPEN ROLES. ITEM 1AB1 80. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DUROSEAU DUROSEAU I GROVE. NO.
GROVE. NO. NO CIERTO. CIERTO.
NO. SKINNER I SKINNER I. ON A
VOTE OF 14 TO 5, THAT ITEM IS
OUT. ITEM NUMBER 2AB2 18. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DAWLEY,
DURAZZO I DUROSEAU I CIERTO. NO.
CIERTO. NO SKINNER I SORRY,
SKINNER. I GROVE. GROVE. NO 14.
THE VOTE IS 14 TO 4. THAT ITEM
IS OUT. OKAY. WE'VE NOW DISPOSED
OF BOTH ITEMS ON THE AGENDA AND
THE COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.